vous posez la question dans un instant
mais auparavant en regardant le
reportage avec votre casquette vous me
faites penser au roi soleil pour moi
soleil oui je m'abrite et 18 ans
c'est très dur regarder aussi parce que
avec une lubie analysé parce qu'ils
aient un peu de brouillard comme ça
regardez un plateau blanc d'en haut
c'est complètement aveugle en mai c'est
un lieu formidable samedi fantastique
alors pourquoi pas plus de
représentations pardon mais il ya 7000
places
vous savez alors en trois jours quand
même ça fait du monde mais aussi ce qui
était fantastique c'est de faire à la
fois quelque chose de psychologique et
de drôles d'humoristique au château pour
700 personnes
quelque chose de beaucoup plus grand
pour que plus explosées est beaucoup
plus moderne finalement sur les eaux sur
le bassin on parlait du roi-soleil
finalement vous avez un point commun
avec louis xiv c'est que lui aussi aimé
et défendez la danse il aimait la danse
la danse et à 14 ans en public à paris
aux tuileries devant des théâtres de
3000 places mais en même temps il avait
une folie et je crois que c'est ça aussi
que j'ai une folie versailles c'est fou
c'est complètement fou le faire
versailles et il l'a fait par des coûts
d'amour pour d'abord les jardins pour
les ardres à nature pour la grandeur et
finalement sur ces gens là qui apportent
à la france une jeunesse éternelle
lorsque la balade à versailles ce qui me
fascine dans les jardins c'est qu'il ya
que des jeunes c'est déjà deux couples
qui pique nique et des enfants qui
s'amusent
il ya énormément de jeunes donc sur des
pôles d'attraction qui 300 plus tard
font venir d'autres gens on sent que les
images de l'enfant roi ce spectacle que
vous donnez donc parallèlement jusqu'à
dimanche donc au château de versailles
à l'opéra royal l'enfant roi pour vous
on le regarde c'est ainsi un triple
symbole l'enfant roi est à la fois trois
rois qui ont été roi à huit ans et demi
à cinq ans et à 4 ans et demi qui les 3
op versailles louis xiii xiv e week end
le dernier roi finalement c'est mozart
qui est presque les mêmes dates que la
vie de louis saez que tu es lorque vous
à faire des châteaux et ce qui est
formidable c'est moi que finalement le
message c'est que le pouvoir dit stick
est supérieur pouvoir politique
on se souvient plus des rois des princes
on se rappelle de mozart et de quelques
grands artistes de molière est ce que
vous me disiez c'est que pour préparer
ses spectacles pour les fabriquer les
élaborer vous avez beaucoup lu sur ces
périodes mais ne peuvent que jeu que
j'aime beaucoup
et dire que mon nom vient de molière de
l'infamie de volières déjà riche des
prêts âge de 12 ans et j'adore cette
période
mais quand même je suis à relire saint
simon dans le lire parce que c'est quand
même six volumes d'appeler à lire tous
les documents de l'époque parce que même
pour insérer une phrase de ligne il faut
trouver la documentation sur sur dix
volumes il ya quelques jours à votre
place se trouvaient patrick dupont qui
disait que vous l'y avait ouvert la
vision du monde coûts liés tout appris
en matière de danse quand on est des
choses pareilles ça vous fait rougir
rougir non ça me rend heureux parce que
je tâche de chaque fois de transmettre à
des jeunes de continuer je crois puisque
est important c'est le rôle de le rôle
de père est pas un père oppressif 1
personne la plus grande liberté à ses
enfants et en même temps en leur donnant
un idéal une voix et un amour vous
parliez tout à l'heure d'éternelle
jeunesse quelle est la recette de votre
éternelle jeunesse
georges est un boulimique éternel jeune
mais je travaille beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup actuellement on joue tous les
soirs on rappelle de l'après midi le
matin je fais des plannings de
répétition parce que j'ai quand même la
compagnie l'école est un groupe en plus
danseurs savais que c'était énorme
normes difficulté et le plateau avec des
entrées sur l'eau les pontons
mais c'est pas du gâteau c'est bien vos
yeux baissés je vois beaucoup travaillé
oui si votre moteur aussi à la fois elle
peut être le stress la peur et puis
veulent le travail mais se dire qu'il
faut chaque fois affronter des endroits
où des textes ou des poèmes ou des
musiques de plus en plus difficile ce
qui n'a pas changé c'est votre regard
vous êtes toujours ses yeux bleus depuis
quand vous connais vous restez avec nous
jusqu'à la fin
oui mal parce qu'on va faire les choses
qui va vous intéresser à notre roi de
france et il s'agit d'henri iv alors le